a two-day teachers training program
facilitated by the president the Senate
Senator Gil aquabio has been concluded
in AUM State the training which took
place from Wednesday to Thursday at aodm
local government area of aquum focused
on information and communication
technology and murder agricultural
practices our correspondent Emmanuel
sales has
details it was a two-day intensive
training for teachers in aquam States as
educators gathered at the c local
government area to upgrade their skills
in information and communication
technology and modern agricultural
practices the training aimed to empower
teachers with the necessary skills to
integrate technology into agricultural
practices thereby enhancing both
teaching methods and productivity some
participants who engaged in interactive
sessions covering topics such as digital
farming techniques the use of mobile
applications for farm management and
strategies for marketing agricultural
products online said the training has
exposed them to new possibilities in
teaching agriculture I've achieved so
many things in this training that I came
for personally it is not only using
chalk to teach in the classroom we are
also asked to use our hands in doing
things like farming trading personally
I'm in love with farming so with those
skill I will be able to advance more
apart from the theorical part we are
asked as a teacher we have to do the the
Practical because of things have changed
it's not only about the theory we have
to go into the Practical aspect of it so
now the Senate President throughout the
small scale and medium Enterprises
agency decided to train teachers to have
other
skills they will be used in ending their
livings it's very interesting because
they talk about communication how to
make use our phone so that we will not
be du by some criminal out there they
tell us about how to to make use of a um
computer phone to avoid problems on your
password or transfer when you want to
transfer money to someone you have to be
careful because if you do mistake give
your code to someone they may use it to
Deb you others admitted that the
training has empowered them with
Innovative tools and technique to
integrate technology into marketing Of
Agricultural Product I'm very very happy
I want to appreciate his Excellency for
for the love that he has for the people
ofia for sending this kind of training
to us we have not been seen such but
through our Senate President we saw all
these thing may God bless him the
training is very very interesting I am
very happy about this program and I even
thank God for those people that have
made provision for this program to
to lift up our knowledge on this most
especially on this computer training so
I am very very happy about and I pray
that God should continue to give the
organizer knowledge and interest on the
teachers in particular in aquam States
also speaking the facilitators
encouraged the participants to share
their knowledge with peers and Implement
Innovative practices in their schools
and communities especially on
information and communication technology
ICT and modern agricultural practice
okay basically the event is just to
equip most importantly teachers and of
course teachers are the very key part of
every child who is going to school you
know child's life and basically they to
equip them with the right information
and today is about the ICT training and
so we have teachers we have um who have
come who have you know come together to
ensure that they have the right
informations right information rather
when it comes to teaching the students
in very
um institution whether primary or
secondary school SM is here to
coordinate it that is part of what we
are staff of sman are here to do like
myself I'm to monitor the program if it
goes with the rules with with the
guideline guideline rules because for of
our program there's a guideline with
Renewed Energy and a wealth of knowledge
the teachers left the training ready to
inspire the Next Generation in modern
agricultural engagements Emmanuel Silas
adbn news